Sind die extreme wetterverhältnisse in der letzten zeit tatsächlich auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen erwischte uns also schon jetzt mit voller breitseite
Die auswirkungen sehen jedenfalls katastrophal. Ihr habt es mitbekommen die
Kanalnetze sind die überhaupt ausgelegt für die folgen des klimawandels ist nämlich wirklich. Skurril wie wird das in zukunft weitergehen
Und können wir uns, irgendwie wartet man das alles jetzt zwar geht es, um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ihr habt alles mitbekommen die letzten jahre waren hinsichtlich der weltweiten temperaturen
Rekordverdächtig nicht nur 2014 2015 und 2016 sondern vor allem auch
2017 war
Außergewöhnlich laut weltwetterorganisation. Wmo
Habe die temperatur 1,1 grad über dem vorindustriellen wert gelegen mit dabei außerdem
Temperaturen von mehr als 50 grad celsius in asien rekord hurricanes in der karibik
Und dem atlantik sowie eine sehr lange dürre in afrika aber wir brauchen gar nicht
So weit weg zu gucken auch hier bei uns in deutschland
Folgt ein unwetter dem nächsten über viersen in nrw liegt
Ein tornado hinweg in wuppertal sind keller und die ganze innenstadt überschwemmt und in der nähe von bochum werden
zwei frauen vom blitz getroffen im saarland werden ganze straßenzüge
Verwüstet gullydeckel schießen nach. Oben unterführung sind vollgelaufen und die innenstädte
Saufen ab essen aachen oder sauce und die liste die kann man ewig weiter fortsetzen
Und das hätte was ganz kurios gezeigt die kanäle in den städten sind nicht für den
klimawandel gerüstet es gibt
Einen sanierungsstau und das obwohl bundesweit rund vier milliarden euro in die. Kanalnetze fließen teilweise sind die
Rohre länger als 50. Jahre boden und bis zu 100. Jahre, alt das muss also dringend
Geändert werden aber ist diese unwetterlage noch normal die antwort ist ganz klar nein normal ist das nicht
Klarkommen unwetter solcher größenordnung schon mal vor aber eben nicht so oft und gehäuft wie in der letzten zeit
Und letztlich ist es keine überraschung wenn man, sich mal. Anschaut dass die atmosphäre
Immer wärmer wird der kreislauf sieht so aus umso wärmer die luft ist desto mehr feuchtigkeit kann
Sie aufnehmen doch diese entlädt, sich dann in form von gewittern samt tage
Sturzfluten sturm und wolkenbrüchen zu erwarten eigentlich eher im hochsommer doch dieses jahr sind wir deutlich früher dran dazu
Passt die rekord wärme im mai in diesem jahr der deutschlandweit mindestens. Zwei grad wärmer war als man nach dem vierjährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre
1981 bis 2010 hätte erwarten können in manchen regionen im norden war es sogar
viereinhalb grad zu warm für das potsdam institut für klimafolgenforschung pik
Ist die lage ganz
Eindeutig mit einer temperatur zunahme von dem jahresmittel einem grad celsius befindet sich deutschland mitten im klimawandel
Als ereignisse können statistisch gesehen zwar? Keinen trend bestätigen aber was wir derzeit an unwetter?
Und lang anhaltender hitze beobachten bestätigt die. Annahme der klimaforscher zu den folgen der globalen erwärmung
So der wissenschafter fred hat man vom pk seiner ansicht nach wird. Sich der derzeitige trend weiter fortsetzen im norden
Und osten wird es immer trockener
Und im süden und westen
Von deutschland werde die gewitter lager weiter akut seien dazu hat man dieser trend wird. Sich fortsetzen wenn der ausstoß von treibhausgasen
unvermindert anhält tatsächlich hatten sich klima forschungsteams lange schwergetan solche extremen
Wetterphänomene in einem direkten zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel, zu bringen doch mittlerweile machen schnelle computer
Und optimierte klimamodelle das möglich in einer großen studie haben 33 forschungsgruppen aus der ganzen welt wetterphänomene
Im jahr 2014 analysiert die entscheidende frage waren die extremwetter ereignisse von
2014 auf natürliche schwankungen klimasystem zurückzuführen oder waren sie tatsächlich folgen des menschengemachten
Klimawandels, thomas kahl einer der beteiligten forscher mit dem fazit wir können demonstrieren dass
einzelne ereignisse wie temperatur extreme oft mit den von uns
zusätzlich in die atmosphäre
gepumpten treibhausgasen verknüpft sind andere extreme darunter regenfälle sind weniger eindeutig auf den klimawandel und
Menschliche, einflüsse zurückzuführen der klimawandel hat also durchaus einfluss auf die häufigkeit. Und spannbreite von solchen extremereignissen
Im jahr 2014 beispielsweise machte man, ihn verantwortlich für die hitzerekorde in europa china argentinien
Und korea und auch für die lange dürre in ostafrika
die starken regenfälle im winter
2013/2014 in großbritannien und die winterstürme seien dagegen nicht klar auf den klimawandel zurückzuführen
Und in zukunft wird das wetter jedenfalls immer nur noch extremer werden dazu. Heiko paeth von der universität würzburg
Wenn, man in der bodennahen atmosphäre mehr in die hat weil die
Treibhausgaskonzentrationen gestiegen sind und einen höheren wärme gehalt in den unteren atmosphärenschichten bedingen dann sollte man
Alleine vom standpunkt der physikalischen plausibilität davon ausgehen dass es in zukunft. Mehr
Extremereignisse lebt wir müssen. Also dringend anfangen uns, zu wappnen. Kommen wir
Noch, mal auf die probleme der kanalisation soll größere kanäle
Zu verlegen das wäre unwirtschaftlich der aufwand wäre gigantisch. Im besten fall. Müsste man verhindern dass die regenmassen überhaupt erst in die
kanalisation gelangen
Dafür müsste das wasser in den boden versickern doch die flächen sind zu stark versiegelt es wäre beispielsweise. Einen anfang flächen wieder
Zu entsiegeln also statt einen parkplatz. Zu asphaltieren mit glitzersteinen pflastern die
Dann, wasser durchlassen doch tatsächlich wird in deutschland. Jeden tag. Mehr als ein
quadratkilometer
Zubetoniert doch das eigentlich große problem ist dass es trotz der ganzen
Um wetter ereignisse der letzten zeit bei vielen leuten nicht. Mehr als schulterzucken auslöst denn. Abgesehen von den stürmen, und
starkregenereignissen haben
Solche unwetter auch langfristige schäden die dann auch nicht mehr nur regional fatale folgen haben werden es drohen ernteausfälle durch trockenheit
Und fischsterben in warmen gewässern was brauchen wir. Noch, mehr an mahnungen ereignissen dass wir endlich alle reagieren
Und was tun schließlich sind wir die. Erste generation die die folgen des klimawandels nicht nur abschätzen kann sondern auch
Hautnah miterlebt vielleicht sind wir auch die letzte generation. Die die katastrophalen folgen für die
Gesamte menschheit noch abwenden kann ich überlege und wenn ich etwas gemeinsam machen. Wollen habt
Ihr ideen schreibt sie unten in die kommentare wenn. Ihr keine videos zum thema klimawandel
Zu anderen allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Dann, um geht, ihr die kaputte aber auch sehr auf youtube im verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
Noch vor allen. Anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert. Einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks, um social nvidia
Abonnieren das geht hier gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier drauf, kriegen aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen und die geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
klimawandel bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleibt da